ce matin de malaisie vietnamiens 128
adultes de 39 cents et 4 nous réfugier à
coups d'obus dont certains d'entre eux
attendaient depuis plus de six mois
qu'un début solidarité nationale des
femmes sortir de l'enfer sélectionnés
parce qu'il parle français ou bien
qu'ils ont de la famille en france et
encore que par le passé 140 personnes
sortir des morilles l'impression franchi
les contrôles sanitaires ses 151
personnes ont été transférées dans des
centres d'hébergement de la région
parisienne à créteil là il passe sous 15
jours pour tenter d'oublier avant d'être
orientés vers des lieux d'accueil défini
aujourd'hui pour chacun d'entre eux la
vie à recommencer les sols peu d'élus
puisque 45 il réfléchit reste encore
april au bidon dans ma ville a retrouvé
à 3-4 secondes
un terminal très souvent son unité
comment
c'est un des très grands a annoncé c'est
quelque chose
qui
la présence générale à l'armement montre
l'importance de ce parfum des entretiens
que ghannouchi renaudat à bagdad
important dans le domaine nucléaire
des contrats les pourparlers
internationale les relations économiques
entre paris et bâle
il a démissionné
soit ils se battent leurs envolées mais
aussi une éthique à leur ambition
n'était pas activement
m
merci
soit
il indiqué